[Music]
hey what's up guys mkbhd here techtober
continues second video of the day today
uh and this is a bit of a different sort
of video typically what i'd be covering
in impressions and first hands on is
things that are coming out right now or
about to come out
this video is a little more of what
microsoft has showed me that's not
coming out this year it's coming out
next year and it has uh sort of a still
being worked on status so there are no
official specs yet but
this is future stuff and microsoft is a
huge company as you know so i went up to
redmond near seattle in their
headquarters and there's dozens and
dozens of labs and experimental areas
that are not normally shown to the
public i saw material labs where they
come up with things like the exact
thickness and texture of their fabric on
the surface laptops and the rubber on
their headphones
where they make prototypes and new
iterations of products that they're
putting together and i even got to spend
some time in the guinness world record
quietest room
in the world one of several anechoic
chambers they've built and used to do
noise testing so out of these microsoft
labs they've showed two things two
future products for next year one is
surface pro neo and the other is surface
pro duo so let's start with the surface
neo it's a tablet sized dual screen
foldable
super thin
and with this 360 degree hinge so just
taking a step back for a second we've
seen different ways to do foldables
right we have the galaxy fold way which
is the folding screen on the inside you
put a screen on the outside that's the
way samsung's chosen to do it or maybe
folding out like the huawei mate x that
doesn't quite exist yet or the royale
flex pi that barely exists or even
vertical foldables like the motorola
razer mockups but the real magic here
with the surface neo is this 360 degree
hinge so this is a different way of
thinking about it so it goes from folded
shut to open but then folds all the way
around so you can use it as a single
screen or you can fold it out flat and
use both screens at the same time there
is a bezel in between so it's not a true
foldable display but the device itself
is foldable and as they're showing it to
me and explaining it to me you know this
is microsoft's chief product officer and
legendary presenter panos paine and he's
showing it to me and i'm realizing even
though this isn't technically a folding
screen it has a lot of the other upsides
of various versions of foldables we've
seen so if you can deal with that bezel
you get the inside screen also being the
outside screen and the outside screen is
the inside screen and it avoids having
to do really any of the complicated
folding display magic altogether that's
been so tricky and then durability is
also safer because you can cover both
sides and protect it when you're done
using it and throw it in a bag or
something and then you don't have to
worry about folding it too far in the
wrong direction because it folds
completely all the way around 360
degrees i think i would only really have
to worry about and you saw it it's super
thin uh like twisting durability
uh and i wasn't gonna test that just
because this is a super precious
prototype and we're just getting our
first look at it but the thinness really
made me think about that and battery
life no idea what a device this thin
could possibly pack in terms of battery
when you're looking at mostly screen but
those are the two things i worry about
this prototype also had magnets in it
and they talked a lot about these
magnets on stage you can have this handy
little tiny keyboard that you slap onto
the bottom and carry around with it and
anytime you want to use it you can swing
it around to the front and now you have
a real physical keyboard and the os
detects what you did with those magnets
and gives you a special sort of ui like
a touch bar on the bottom display or you
can use it as a track pad that's really
clever and this is all coming from
what's called windows 10 x so basically
a fork of windows designed specifically
for this new dual screen
form factor i think i'm just going to
call it dual screen so it's going to
manage you know continuity between the
two sides if you open something on one
side and it windows out to the other
screen all the sorts of things like that
and the magnet is also good for holding
that surface slim pen as well which has
magnets inside so it can be clamped on
the outside if you just want to keep it
there but it also can just sit there and
chill on the back if you're not using it
so this was fascinating i was i was
impressed by and intrigued by the whole
360 degree hinge surface neo dual screen
folding action idea it kind of reminds
me of something a lot of you guys have
been sending me i think it's a
sort of phone designer mock-up of like
the dream form factor for laptops over
the past couple days but there was one
more thing too there's room for
something a bit smaller more portable
pocketable even
and that would be where we saw the
surface duo so the surface duo is like a
pocket version of the neo so now it's a
pair of smaller relatively 5.5 inch
screens next to each other again with a
small bezel in the middle that make it
sort of taller or longer or wider
however you want to say it when it's
unfolded but same idea here 360 degree
hinge
fully protected no screen on the outside
so it's totally safe in your pocket like
a normal phone or maybe in a bag
and again it's super thin which who
knows what that means for battery but it
looks really sleek and the hinge weight
was what struck me the most about this
prototype form really if the hinge is a
little too loose folding it out will not
feel secure and it'll fall over if you
try to put it on a table but if the
hinge is too tight it's not comfortable
to fold and unfold so the hinge weight
was great uh felt looked kind of like a
bigger version of that motorola razor
concept and possibly the most
interesting thing they told us is
it runs android so that means microsoft
and google working together to create a
version of android or some modifications
to android that again work better with
this dual screen folding phone concept
the same way that they worked on windows
for the surface neo and that's again to
have dual screen apps you know one app
on one screen one app on the other
android is already building in features
now for foldables but i assume this is
another continued step in that direction
as microsoft sets its sights on this new
future form factor so i don't know about
you but i love this i love the
commitment i want to see them really
make this you know we had a little
hiccup there in the beginning of folding
phones but it seems like now we're back
to full steam ahead as we start to get
folding phones shipping now we have
galaxy fold shipping we have the huawei
mate x delayed but hopefully coming soon
and now we have this commitment from
microsoft and it seems like we're back
on this wave so we had you know folding
phones with flip phones and now the form
factor of the future may actually be big
screens getting small and then getting
big again but i'm curious what you think
of this 360 degree hinge as a foldable
phone concept again it's not really
truly a folding screen and there is a
tiny bezel in the middle and the way
they use that might be interesting but
let me know what you think in the
comment section below either way that's
been it just a quick video to share some
of this fun future new stuff and again
like i mentioned that interview talking
tech with microsoft ceo satya nadella is
coming up so tech tober continues
thanks for watching
catch you guys the next one
peace